bindi Irwin celebrated Australia's  Father's Day with a sweet tribute to her  late father Crocodile Hunter Steve Irwin  on Sunday bindi posted a photo of her  dad training a crocodile with a caption  that said in part no matter where I am  in the world this day means such a lot  to me my heart forever lives Australia  Zoo just like dad's always did come on  you when I have a look at the elephant  in the back of it trucky it's a big one  it's a whopper  September 4th marks the 9th anniversary  of Steve Irwin's 2006 death bindi was  just 8 years old you know he inspired so  many people that we want to make sure  that his legacy lives on through all of  us bindi is currently in the u.s. with  pro partner Derek Hough for her Dancing  with the Stars debut on September 14th  I heard the dad would be proud of me  because you know he is he's my superhero  and he always will be